hey guys this is Vine with maxtech and
in this video I want to showcase an
entire Suite of chargers and power Banks
from our sponsor bases which are perfect
for the new iPhone 15s and of course the
latest new Macbook Pros and basically
any other device you may have we've got
two awesome laptop power Banks two
charging stations and a bunch of mac
safe battery packs including one that's
incredibly unique so let's get started
with the power Banks first here I have
the bases Adan 65 wat and the Adan 140 W
power Banks which both come with very
large capacities 20,000 Mah hours on the
65 and
24,000 on the 140 WT which is insane and
perfect for travel both of these have a
digital display to show the percentage
of battery left as well as other
important data like the voltage and
amperage and they're both compatible
with over 1,000 devices on the market
with fast charging protocols now the 65w
version is perfect for emergency
charging laptops like the MacBook Air as
well as other devices like the steam
deck and other handheld gaming consoles
it has four USB ports including two USB
as a micro USB and USB C Port so you can
charge multiple devices at once and it
supports reverse 60 W fast charging for
the battery Bank itself now the 140 W
model supports PD 3.1 charging which
means 140 WS of power which is perfect
for the 16-in MacBook Pro which also
accepts exactly 140 WTS of power it has
three USB ports with one usba a and two
USBC so you can actually charge two
laptops at once like the MacBook Air and
a MacBook Pro at the same time which is
really convenient or you can use all
three ports with optimized power
distribution to charge various devices
like laptops cell phones tablets Etc it
also supports 100 W reverse input
charging for the battery Bank itself so
it charges up incredibly quickly in just
30 minutes so like I said before this
one is definitely the one you want if
you have a 16-in MacBook Pro just
because of the flexibility of being able
to fully fast charge every device you
have and of course you can always use it
for your iPhone 15 and any other devices
you have so it's a great choice now
moving on to these Max safe battery
packs bases actually has four of them to
choose from but I'm going to start with
these three that each support 20 watts
of charging recommended by CNN unored as
one of the fastest charging and
recharging models that they've tested
they have options of either 20,000
milliamp hours of battery which is over
six times the amount of the battery in
the iPhone 15 Pro which is just crazy
and then they have 10,000 milliamp hours
which is over 3 times the battery and
they finally have the 6,000 Mah model
which is just incredibly Slim So it's a
must have for travel since you can
simply slip it into your pocket together
with your iPhone and it's so easy to
carry and it's also got a soft silicon
surface on the inside that's not going
to scratch your iPhone now these Max
safe battery packs give you the most
convenient way to charge since you
simply use the powerful magnets with mag
safe to attach it to the back of any
iPhone since the iPhone 12 giving you
7.5 WS of charging power and the size
perfectly fits all iPhones including the
mini models without overhanging on the
bottom and it doesn't hit the new camera
module bumps on the iPhone 15 Pro Models
and the best part about all three of
these is the fact that they support up
to 20 watts of fast charging using the
USBC ports on the bottom which you you
can see right here with the included
charging cables so you can quick charge
your iPhone 15 Pro to 50% in only 30
minutes even better they could be fully
charged in under 2 hours with an 18w PD
charger and making it even more unique
you can actually pass through charge by
plugging your charging cable directly
into the power bank itself and then it's
going to charge both your phone and the
battery pack to 100% at the same time
and now let's talk about the basis let's
see magnetic power bank which has 10,000
Mah hours of battery power and also
supports two-way charging of either 7.5
W Max safe or even better 30 W USBC PD
fast charging using the super convenient
builtin PD cable this right here is
awesome because unlike other battery
Banks this one holds on to your iPhone
using Mac safe and the built-in cable
makes it nice and and compact unlike
other long cables that are all over the
place even better the 18w built-in cable
supports fast charging input so you
don't need another one to charge it but
this battery Bank also includes another
USB C port for charging two devices at
once I'd say that this is definitely the
best out of the bunch since the new
iPhone 15 Pro Models support up to 27
wats of power so it's perfect for giving
you the maximum charging speed possible
and you can use any leftover battery
life to charge other devices so it's
probably the best Max safe battery bank
that I've seen and now let's finish off
with these two awesome power combo
charging stations which are the best
charging solutions for desktop setups
this one is the 35 wat version which
comes with a built-in display to show
the load status digital protection and
grounded indicators and it also features
a bunch of comprehensive smart safety
protections like auto shutdown which
activat activates in 0.1 seconds to
eliminate safety hazards and protect
Electronics from short circuits fire
hazards and potential electrical dangers
with overload overcurrent over voltage
and under voltage protection as well as
1200 J Surge and lightning protection to
protect against Power surges voltage
spikes and lightning strikes this is
essentially a 10in One charging station
with a nice vertical space saving design
with six AC power outlets around them
that you can plug various things into as
well as two USBC ports and two usba a
ports which can output 35 WS of charging
power using Gan 5 technology to charge
multiple devices using basa power split
2.0 to redistribute the power if
multiple devices are plugged in finally
there's the power combo Pro 100 wat
charging station which has the same
built bu in 1200 J surge protection and
9 plus safety protection features and IT
Supplies a maximum of 100 WS which is
great for high-speed charging of phones
tablets and laptops like the 16in
MacBook Pro up to 45% in 30 minutes it
packs seven outputs including two USBC
two usba a and three AC outlets for
seven device sign simultaneous charging
while being very Compact and portable
thanks to hyper Gan technology so it's
ideal for bringing on trips and it also
comes with a smart touch switch control
within the power button with three
pulsing modes indicating charging status
and it actively cuts the power off to
protect your charging safety these power
stations are really special because you
can use them for your desktop setups
like an iMac setup or clamshell MacBook
Pro setup while having such a large
availability of ports giving you freedom
to charge anything you need so with all
that said here is the full lineup from
bases including their Adan power Banks
their Max safe battery packs including
the 30 W let C USBC model and of course
the power combo power stations and you
can find links to each and every one of
these basis products down in the
description below along with the
discount information as well so
hopefully you enjoy this video thanks
for watching and we'll see you in the
next one